Oh
what is afflicting the working class in
America today in a word loneliness
for starters marriage is in retreat
while two-thirds of college-educated
women are married at age 40 that's true
of half of 40 year old women who never
went to college
divorce is much more common among non
college Americans most children born to
poor or working-class mothers today are
born out of wedlock and this is part of
a much bigger problem the institutions
that bring people together providing
stability support modeling and purpose
those institutions are disappearing from
working-class America while the
college-educated in this country
increasingly cloister into elite
enclaves the college-educated still
generally have robust institutions of
civil society such as good public
schools tight-knit neighborhoods and
professional associations among the
working class though life is
increasingly deinstitutionalized less
social trust less belonging particularly
blessed church so the working class
isn't merely less likely to get ahead
today they're more likely to be
struggling alone my new book alienated
America is about these working-class
struggles to learn more about it check
the link in the description below also
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI